my talk today is called able fight or
always be integrating your lost function
of your posterior estimate so hopefully
we'll have some fun firstly I work for
Schmidt Futures Schmidt features is a
philanthropic effort by Erica Mooney
Schmidt our founders and it is a talent
focused philanthropy or film shop
together we basically focus on people if
you can think of this top row here as
being our people programs I'll get into
minute in a little while but we take
really young people Roth raw talented
people and we help them gain vision and
exposure we take people who are starting
to prove themselves and we give them the
resources to to focus on a new exciting
idea and we take proven stars and we
help them scale how do we do this well
we've got explicit talent programs but
we also do grant making in a more
traditional sense for enabling
technologies and one of these enabling
technologies well things like new
datasets and tools and also things like
infrastructure everything from dinner
parties through to you know trying to
convince presidents of universities to
create new departments just to give you
a little bit of idea of what sort of
talent programs we have going at the
moment we have the in the raw talent
bucket one of them would be the APM
there's actually based on Google's
associate product manager role we take
brilliant young people these are CS grad
straight out of MIT and Stanford and we
put them we give them really hard jobs
basically we placed them into people who
are into teams who are doing very
exciting work normally slightly academic
work and a whole bunch of training as
well an example of an innovative rising
or mid tier program talent program is
our MIT science fellows this is a super
exciting program we basically get 20 of
the world's smartest scientists there's
a postdocs and we pay them to change
fields so we take like a physicist and
put them in a cancer lab and they get
training and they get like a really
really
good stipend they get like double what
you'd get in a typical typical postdoc
and as an example of a scale level
talent program we take like really
senior academics you know MacArthur
grant Mina is that sort of thing and we
help them get the teams underneath them
in order to build out new infrastructure
so a great example of that is some work
we're doing with sandal mile Nathan at U
Chicago he's getting all this data from
different hospital systems and creating
a research platform that will allow
people like you know CS PhD students to
access data health data really
high-quality health data with only you
know a couple of days of waiting once
you submit your forms rather than having
to you know do data usage agreements
with a hospital system for six months
really exciting work my talk today is
slightly on the career end of things and
it's because people keep on asking what
I do and I don't really have much of a
word for it I like to think of the world
of data science as having three kind of
tiers it depends on like essentially who
the audience is and what you're trying
to optimize at the bottom here these are
tools for automation they're kind of you
know never take a perfectly good job
from a computer sort of work that's when
you're building you know tools they're
going to use over and over the whole
notion of putting something into
production in the middle we've got tools
that augment the abilities of humans so
this could be anything from models that
help you understand the world to know
dashboards to all this sort of stuff
a bee testing is a great example where
you are helping your running experiments
in order to improve product design at
the top is this kind of field that does
exist it certainly exists and I don't
think we we have a name for it so I like
to call it like executive data science
it's a sort of data science that answers
research questions that senior
executives have and so this might be
like strategic positioning you know what
sort of product offering should affirm
have in order to position itself within
a market prioritization of management
you might want to think of say a
customer lifetime value model as being
not only
addictive entity but a causal one as
well there are all those elements all
those parameters of a customer lifetime
value model are actually things that you
might be able to influence you know what
sort of advertising campaigns or sales
techniques or whatever or you know
effort of your organization can change
the parameters in your CLV measurement
of key results or kpi's this is a really
difficult thing to do if you're if
you're building key results or KPIs that
are biased by the growth of a company
then they're not very good kpi's right
you want to get scale invariant kpi's
and also like basic economics a macro
view how uncertainly out are we about
the environment that we work in so it's
what I call executive data science I
think that data scientists have this
unique toolkit to be really great
executives that's because we're like
really cynical statisticians a great
cynical statistician is Deirdre
McCloskey she's actually an economist
but she teaches like English and history
and all sorts of things I think you
should read this I'll read it for you
if someone call help help in a faint
voice in the midst of lots of noise so
it's that the 1% level of significance
their satisfactory low probability that
you'll be embarrassed B be embarrassed
by false alarm
it could be that she's saying kelp kelp
which arose perhaps because she was in a
heated argument about a word proposing a
game of Scrabble you wouldn't go to the
rescue and this really gets to the core
problem of decision theory okay that we
want to make decisions and we do have
highly nonlinear responses given some
piece of information so why should you
think about it well it's really
intuitive you probably do it already
there are new are tools that can make
this a lot easier formally but I don't
even think you need to do it formally in
order to get the majority of the benefit
you certainly should learn to do it
formally but it's one of those things
where simply knowing that it exists it
gets you most of the way there knowing
that something exists
you know enough to put you in the frame
of mind where you can start to
incorporate uncertainty into your
decision-making you know more systematic
way
okay so let's use an example I'm not a
health person I will happily admit but
we're we're going to look at a new type
of chemotherapy let's say there's a
definitely terminal type of cancerous or
it's definitely going to kill you and
there's some some medicine some pill I
can give someone and I'll do a
randomized controlled trial and I'll see
how much longer the treatment group
lives than the control group right so I
get it I run my ass here and get a
causal estimate there are a couple of
wrinkles of this right it's costly to
implement chemotherapy is horrible okay
it it's expensive it hurts the person
who's getting chemotherapy and so it's
there's some costs to its implementation
it also has diminishing returns on on
welfare so if you're like 85 you're
probably going to die pretty soon right
so extending your life on from this
condition of like five years you might
not evaluate in very much because that
you might die of something else you know
five years right you might actually or
you might just be discounting you don't
really care about the future very much
also at the expected effect size what we
estimate in our model it has a positive
effect you think look at the expected
value I am better off in doing this
they're not doing it should you take it
well I haven't given you enough
information so let's take a plot here so
let's first of all focus on the middle
one that's our loss function if it has
zero and negative effect let's just say
that I incur the costs I'm going to pay
for the medicine I'm going to be really
really sick for a while and if it if it
doesn't make me live any longer I'm
still gonna die so I'll just get like
really sick and poor for a little while
before I die and then there's this big
bump if it works a little bit if it
extends my life then I'm happy but by by
the time I'm down here I'm probably
going to die of something else so if I'm
pushing four years additional life it's
not going to help me at the same time we
can take our
posterior estimate of the treatment
effect okay that's the the bell curve
here we read and run it ran a randomized
control trial we get some estimate and
and we get some posterior here this
posterior it's got a you know I'm just
going to say the we'll call this like a
p-value of like one percent or something
one of the bit percent masses of
probability in the positive space it is
almost certainly going to work should I
take the medicine well what you need to
do is integrate your loss function over
this density now what I mean by that we
can ask yourself how happy am i if the
effect size is too if you've exercises
too I can go down here and I can read
off what the house had I am at what if
it's for well I can read off how sad I
am what if it's zero I can read off how
sad I am I can do that for all possible
treatment effect sizes and then I take
I've just simply taking the weighted
average of this in this and that gives
me the posterior density times loss and
this is what I need to integrate so
let's there we are
so the red bit here is bad that's loss
I don't want read the green bit there is
is happiness right that's additional
life so red bit was a green bit - red
bit or the red bit - green bit gives me
my net loss and it turns out with this
parameterization although you would you
would take this medicine if you were a
four cuentas and just taking the modal
estimator and saying yeah I'm better off
at that point you would not do it here
the loss the expected loss outweighs
expect to benefit from this medication
so able flip is all you need to remember
always be integrating your loss function
over your posterior estimate easy to
remember easier to do okay so let's talk
a step back a little bit we heard about
stand before and and posterior so let's
just talk about what a posterior is and
I'm really easy to get setting so take a
simple linear generative model we've got
intercept slope
and normal noise so I can plug in any
values of a and B and Sigma into this
and for a given X I can simulate some
some values of potential wires right
that's what makes a generative model I
can generate new data from it what is it
in practical terms well at the moment
all I've done is like I've drawn from my
prior I can parameterize this I can
simulate some facts out of it that data
is completely meaningless
I want the parameter estimates I've got
a B and Sigma to have some bearing on on
the problem I'm I'm working with okay so
we condition these values on Y and X and
if we've got small data then we're going
to especially get a lot of benefit from
having sensible informative priors the
reason I became a Bayesian was because I
was working in sub-saharan African
finance and by the time one of our cup
clients came to us they told us
something important which was we we
aren't dead yet we have our company
hasn't exploded though the shocks in
those tails that you see nearly as big
as the ones that are out there so in
practical terms what we get from our
Bayesian estimate is a posterior and
this posterior you can think of it as
being like a data frame and we've got
it's doesn't have a laser we've got our
a B and Sigma and we've got all these
draws of a B and Sigma from our
posterior okay so these summarize how
uncertain we are about the values are in
our models the parameter is in our model
what does that mean in practical terms
well remember if we go back I told you
for any bet a B and Sigma I can simulate
some values of Y okay I can simulate my
model I'd get some fake belt some fake
data so what I can do is for each each
row each drawer of my posterior I can
simulate some fake outcomes with
different actions an action might be an
element in my model where I'm perturbing
something I'm saying take the pill don't
take the pill right and I can simulate
these outcomes that might be
why for whatever you care about now for
each of those I have a loss function and
all I need to do is for under action 1
I've got my my posterior predictive
drawers for action - I've got my
posterior predictive drawers and I just
need to map each of those onto my loss
function ok because the outcome is the
thing that I care about and then I just
take the expected value I take the mean
of these two columns now statistical
decision Theory might sound complex but
all it is is doing this exercise for
each of the potential decisions that
you're making and making the choice that
minimizes your expected loss that's it
really simple the tools that you can use
in are for this the stand family of
tools are fantastic as you all know -
stand itself is language it's an
amazingly expressive language I do
almost all of my work and stand but
there are two great up api's we've got
BRMS and austin arm they do similar
things in slightly different syntax BRMS
is building some really cool stuff at
the moment so is austin arm if you're
more of a tree person than Bayesian
additive regression trees or bark are
really cool they're great for if you go
and run a randomized control trial and
you want to estimate that response
surface so you've got some non-linear
response surface and Bart - really
really clever way of discovering that
and so that's kind of most most
associated with jennife hill one bit
sorry
so there's Bart machine D Bart and Bart
cause the packages you might want to
check out there but they all have this
this really impressive feature which is
that they've got uncertainty in the
parameters okay they told you a little
bit about wholesale learning in
sub-saharan Africa so the company a
company I advise I used to be had about
its data unfair they do asset-backed
learning in sub-saharan Africa so this
because domestic wholesale learning
rates are really really high and so
lendable just like basically takes these
know that these companies who lend out
cows or motorcycles or solar panel or
whatever takes those companies and plug
them into the global financial system
right so they are able to take their
receivables and
securitize them and raise wholesale rate
amounts of money at attractive interest
rates so does this buy securitisation
now what in sub-saharan Africa these
debt portfolios can have very very high
losses and very very big shocks this is
not a riskless asset class and so it
really matters when you're evaluating
the pricing a portfolio of debt you need
to have some sense of what potential
outcomes are out there and as I said
before if all the customers who come to
you exist and they probably probably do
exist but if they do exist and they
haven't gotten broke yet then the
details that you see in their data are
way too small and so you need to use a
sensible prior information about the how
big shocks can be okay and so we
simulate the cash flows from this from
the from a portfolio of debt and you
could take each of these lines and plug
it into a cash flow waterfall anyone who
they worked in finance knows it isn't
like this entire accounting system that
goes alongside the equity prices and
dividends that's also people owned these
receivables and they get paid off and
lawyers get paid off and there's
something for exchange rate and all that
sort of so it depends when the the cash
flow happens it has different values and
so you need to take these these cash
flows and plug them in through your
accounting system and only then do you
get to aggregate across those and get an
economically meaningful decision will
quantity what is the expected gain to
the business of buying this portfolio at
different prices so we built that and
kind of automate it and kind of runs in
the cart every day okay so example 3 is
with philanthropy and this gets past the
world where we have data on anything ok
so I'm trying to make investments in
people and in projects that haven't even
happened yet this is not even causal
inference this is like storytelling ok
so what we need to do is think and what
otherwise our thinking is you know if
we're like crass utilitarians we might
think look the further someone is away
from me
well I draw a circle around myself and
make that circle bigger and bigger and
bigger and there are going to be more
people who are whom I could potentially
affect the big that circle is right and
you know this circle might be time it
might be how far into the future I'm
willing to look okay or it might be
network distance so how many you know
shared connections away do we need to go
in order to access a larger network or
it might be space you know am i
considering the welfare of people in
Chad or New Zealand which is a very long
way away so as you go further away you
get a lot more people you could
potentially affect at the same time my
ability to affect them at the moment I'm
torturing you with decision theory but
if you're outside you wouldn't be you
wouldn't be troubled by that at all so
my ability to affect you is diminishing
in the distance and there might be
distance in time it might be distance in
in distance or and network or whatever
but I'm I'm going to have less effect on
you now if you're a philanthropist what
you're trying to do is maximize your
impact on the things that you care about
right so you really want the you want to
integrate your effect size which you're
uncertain about over the number of
people number of units or you tools you
know if you've read it you know some of
the crazy utilitarians like to think
about us all being m's simulated in the
in a cloud in distant future and how
much weight do we want to give those
things and so this can help you guide
the the distance at which you were
likely to have the biggest impact now of
course it's going very depending on what
you're investing in and and what sort of
tools you have yours-- puzzle thank you
very much we're exactly on time
you